my name is markiplier and welcome to the
resident evil 3 demo featuring the
wonderful the horrible nemesis I don't
know if you heard me say that twice or
just once I did it twice just in case
because this is live welcome everybody
hello hello from the comfort of your own
homes hope you're staying safe hope you
are staying healthy and hope you are
ready for a little bit of Resident Evil
action going on here it's gonna be fun
this one crept up out of nowhere I kind
of forgot about this one and don't get
me wrong tomorrow
tomorrow my tomorrow my playthrough of
headphones can't do that my playthrough
of doom eternal doth begin in earnest
tomorrow we are starting doom eternal
and I have never been more excited about
a game in a long long time but right now
we have Resident Evil three looking at
us right in the face the demo about a
year after the last one came out a
little more this game is nearly here I
don't know if you guys can still hear me
with this helmet on but it's gonna be a
lot of fun and it's going to be just
it's gonna be fun so doom eternal starts
tomorrow but right now all right now
we've got Resident Evil to go through
also if you want to check out the new
cloak collection check it out through
the link in the description below go to
cloak brand calm we've got some stuff
that I think you're gonna like go quick
because a lot of it is selling out very
quickly alright with that being said
everyone should be here for this demo
I'm ready to go it's probably gonna be
like 45 minute experience I think that's
what the last one was also let me know
if the volume is either too loud or too
quiet the final game may differ from
this demo you cannot save or load your
game in this demo hence why we're doing
it live this new plague is spreading at
a terrified
great very topical hello
captain let's find a way to could use
our help Carlos you didn't even think
the worst fine young lady your name she
is an elite operative of our LPT special
tactics and Rescue Service
her name is something Valentine its Jill
nice to meet you Jill I am upcs platoon
leader mikail Victor my team was sent
here to rescue civilians right how's
that going for you this city is
completely cut off isolated most of the
hundred thousand civilians will wind up
dead correction and death my platoon has
suffered serious losses just keeping
them alive is more than I can manage
well you can thank your corporate
overlords for that yes well we are doing
all we can if we can get this subway
train moving we can have a q8 some
survivors but we need help my men cannot
do this alone
alright I'm in yeah Jill that's cool we
don't want the same thing Thank You Jill
sorry super cop there you go
we can use this to stay in contact I
know what a radio is first we need to
get you geared up head up to street
level
you'll find supplies there all right all
right
this dudes hair it's just my god I
didn't know I was in this game for power
he knows the strategy that I know all
about what are you doing to his crotch
listen I can barely see it
[Laughter]
you guys want volume up or down how is
the volume on that little bit right
there for you guys watching in the
future sit tight we're gonna make it
perfect for you
we're gonna make it we're gonna make it
perfect pristine for you we're gonna
make it so it was good good volume I
mean that was a cutscene so I don't know
who's there who the hell do you think
you are volume ah I can't up up okay
volume up you got it volume is up
[Music]
alright so those douche bags are over
there up good alright I'll just do it I
can't see this is what I used to be like
in high school this is like the
hairstyle I had so he was really
emulating what I got going on here
alright left click for a handgun ammo oh
god I forgot how much I loved playing
Resident Evil 2 on the battlefield if
you're out of ammo your guns about as
useful as a wet fart one stay alive out
there to get these basic formulas in
your skull gunpowder gunpowder gunpowder
hi Greg
powdered Calgary man you're stocked up
get out there and join the party let's
give these dead mother just something to
eat just make sure you don't become
dizzy
okay good God family friendly please oh
Science Forum resident evil 3 hey that's
trip punch
Big E Big E is that that guy's name is
that Big E over there with the Big E
hairstyle oh I bet it is that's got to
be Big E alright so let's get to this I
forgot because I loved the gameplay of
the first game I really did a Resident
Evil 2 holy crap there was no need look
big E's on the scene Big E is ready to
dish out some Bulleit desserts for
everybody here you don't want to get in
the way of Big E when Big E walks into
town
hello what do we have here uh huh
tabloid front-page cannibal murder is a
complete digest in the gray of the
morning on September 25th a frantic
caller telephone the our PD to report an
assault the man described as a
disheveled like a vagrant was attacking
a passerby north of the Lambs Museum of
Art the responding officers discovered a
mutilated corpse of a woman by some
dumpsters nearby dozens of bite marks
covered her body and she had been
dismembered she says she had been eaten
and the third known incident in this
kind to occur in Raccoon City this month
so whodunit who's been munching on man
steak he we here at news come we're at
news comment of a gnawing feeling of the
so called cannibal disease page
dispenser memorial has been providing
free treatments for the since August it
might not be settling for just the
cafeteria food our reporters have
infiltrated Spencer Memorial that's the
tough questions come back with horror
stories that will make your stomach
Royall turn the page for the scoop there
is no more page there is no more page
there so I can't exactly read anything
else
I'm guessing that this isn't actually an
exit here and is it still whoa I can
dodge now that was not a thing before
that was most certainly not a thing oh
my god I can actually dodge is the knife
useless or copy that let's do this let's
do this big oh my god I can actually
dodge that's sick that is sick okay all
right I'm gonna just probably start
cramping things together just because
I'm not gonna worry about trying to
ration things there we go yeah just
because if I worry about rationing
things on a demo I don't think I'm gonna
make any progress in it's gonna hit the
end of the game before I actually need
to do anything all right
let's change out though this is gonna go
to one you know shortcut one okay I just
like melee being on one I know you you
tick and bam oh yes please baby let me
combine you oh crap I forgot it's it's
uh it's green green green and then red
green is equivalent to a big God I
I shouldn't have combined I shouldn't
have such an it I shouldn't have done it
guys
Biggie's let you down who just poured a
glass of tea who the hell Oh God you
yeah yeah I love the stabbed way better
than a slice let me tell you that Oh Oh
dancin alright there's no place like the
uvcs for pip squeeze who crawl back to
the base every single time they get
scratched up you want somebody to kiss
your boo-boo go someplace else here in
the big leagues we mix our own meds so
we get these recipes memorized green
green green red or green green green god
damnit I'm an [ __ ]
can't make these yourself grandma if you
see them that should do it let's get
this done and go grab a beer I didn't
know this was the Department of Bros
growing it up during the zombie
apocalypse more like the bro pocalypse
let's get some zombies oh crap
all right good call going down there
okay first off I'm gonna see how lethal
this knife is I bet it's not me you went
to me this no no no yeah
dodge oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you wish
you wish turns out they wished all over
me yeah yeah all right I'm doing
experimentations because I need to see
how lethal the knife is so if I die okay
if I die it's fine guys don't worry
about I just need to see how lethal this
is and the answer is not at all what is
the point of this thing is this no point
all right screw it
I've gotten my answer it's if the answer
is not lethal at all bang you done you
done no you done
that's cool move yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah wah
what's whoa all right so that was
pointless and now I'm infected Brawley
oh well whatever worse things have
happened to better people so I can't
complain I can't see a goddamn thing
through my fluffy hair alright I'll get
there
wow he's dead huge audio lag what is
there a problem with the audio no no no
don't tell me that
no no audio is totally off how is the
audio totally off okay banging the dick
you didn't that wasn't that wasn't good
how many people right now who who who
audio good audio bad audio lag what did
I do
it's because I updated OBS it's because
I updated OBS I swear to go no no it's
good what hmm no lag huh
I think some people are audio is fine
it's good is off it's good okay if it's
off refresh if it's off go refresh your
your browser browser see if that fixes
it
hopefully audios good okay I'm gonna
assume it's good oh hey oh god yes
please
hello hi stop at you oh you stop it - I
[Laughter]
forgot how satisfying that could be oh
yes please you need a little soup to the
brain oh oh not quite so done oh there
we go that's now you're done dick in the
dick in the soup - the dick it's a soup
catheter straight to the balls like yeah
alright okay now let's get serious
what are we doing oh that poor person
okay
ah that looked like I might be able to
break it
nah damn okay huh
hello hi good to see ya come on good
gunpowder those guys are probably gonna
break through at some point yep I knew
it
I am a tall drink of water you are
correct about that your correctamundo oh
yes please
oh hey nope thought that was gonna be it
Oh turns out I need to do something
about it knife it use it all right so I
need to find some kind of a kind of like
a wrench or something or a big old
monkey wrench maybe oh yeah yeah yeah I
knew it Danny strong okay now the
question of the day is does that red
barrel explode this is my biggest
question come on oh god I am just as
good as I ever was at this game just as
good in fact probably better way way way
better oh okay yeah bullets in grandma's
donut shop that seems like the most
likely place for bullets who the hell do
you think you are all right don't trust
that okay fine whatever you say whatever
you say oh those must be locks that I
can do those must be huh if you're
having trouble with the the video lags
just try dropping the quality to that
might also be something that's causing a
bit of an issue hello
Oh safe room Oh perfect and then I can
do this
combine a fat forget that I can take
this boom I'm all good okay cool
and is that a monkey wrench or bolt
cutters sure I'll do that I'm gonna put
this in here until I find another one
for it oh wait bolt cutters can I use
that for the ah I thought maybe but
apparently not
okay hey bot stay down please stay oh
you definitely stick hat fall fall oh
thank you all right you live right I
probably shouldn't waste bullets on
people on the ground it does seem like
this game is probably gonna be a bit
more gunplay than the other games and a
lot more City exploration I never played
resident evil 3 I only know a little bit
about Jill Valentine story but you got
backup no let me see if this can help I
do like that the knife isn't just a
giant piece of crap knives should last a
lot longer than they have in these games
but they're still very wimpy against
actual zombies so there's only so much
that I can get out of it
kaboom stirs yeah
no I don't trust I knew it I knew it I
knew it I knew it
life does nothing knife does nothing
knife does absolutely dick and diddly
Wow
hey bud I'll take that thank you oh my
god I did I I haven't even been paying
attention to the environment that's
gnarly oh you died all right cool
I don't know if there's anything that I
can get out of the demo from that big a
like Big E like pretty good does that
mean that I'm gonna get a shotgun
anytime soon does that mean I get a big
kaboom or anytime soon oh you not for
long blue your hat right off oh yes
please I'm finding all the goodies I do
like the kind of idea that there's more
like exploration to be had about it
there's more just like nuance to it
there's more subtlety there's more
there's more things to be found you know
things to overlook it is it is very much
like this staircase here I'm never
seeing that there's a lot more things to
just kind of like wander around oh yeah
where am I oh you fell you went kaboom
oh yeah I like this I like this a lot
that actually startled me of not
prepared for that yeah nope nope
what let me dodge dodge dodge dodge okay
miss sweetness sweetness Sweetman all
the misses I'm not trust you Inc God you
suck oh that actually got you nice yeah
that scared me yeah that uh that scared
me that scared me
scared me yeah biggie done normally get
scared like that but you know you know
it is okay alright drug store owners
Journal this new hair tonic from
umbrellas is fly-fish that's what Big E
uses to get big air umbrella hair tonic
the stuff they make always works wonders
this so it's no surprise I was counting
on this and ordered a huge shipment my
instincts are paying off literally I
just know sales will rise continue to
rise the word gets out that said the
string of violent incidences on the news
as we worried maybe I had to invest in a
good safe to hold all this cast is
rolling in the new safe code is just
perfect no one knows the code not even
my wife nineties with my wife it's a
secret between me and my beautiful aqua
cure queen and she'd never give it up
for a thief oh really
your aqua cure queen huh aqua cure queen
huh interesting very interesting now
where oh where is there a map or
something
there is Oh Oh interesting
okay so pharmacy I missed a red herb in
there somehow that was the drug store
owner's journal and that would be the
pharmacy so there's got to be an aqua
queen style thing in there that would be
suggestive
of what this safe code would be you know
what I'm saying
Oh maybe one of these nah no it would
definitely be it would definitely be
something over in the drugstore I'm
willing to bet I bet I just bet I just
bet just like I just bet that you guys
are staying clean staying healthy
keeping your studies up even at home and
washing your hands with almost religious
reverence I'm gonna make I might just
make shotgun shells anyway I don't know
if I'm gonna use them I don't know if I
have a purpose firm but just to clear my
inventory exacta sounds of a zombie
munching hungry sue posture I don't know
why the ridiculousness of that very
funny very funny god dammit I just
combined that I'm an idiot all right I
need to BLAP two bullets cause I'm
getting kind of full up we're even am i
right now how did I make it all the way
up here it's on fire yo yeah a little
bit ooh love it love it
want more of it okay so somewhere in the
drugstore there's bound to be an aqua
queen Oh what the hell what the hell oh
really
can I sneak
now there's no sneaking but I do wonder
is there a sneak wait hang on I got a
look at I don't know if there's actually
controls nah there's no sneaking I can't
execute a zombie Oh mmm boy I guess I
can and boy I miss okay cool
hotness now there we go there we go
that's the good stuff okay so where was
this I can't I see I can't see
no there's nothing by me no don't don't
even try don't even try to mess with me
don't even try don't there's definitely
no there's no way how am I here how do I
like it here
I'm confused I'm very confused oh okay
all right okay all right okay all right
Bokke
all right aqua queen guys everyone pay
attention a healthy family is a happy
family you know this game this games
topical this game topical very very
topical very topical Queen anybody
seeing a aqua queen oh my god Oh
Vava voom escaped ecstasy
yeah no no one's gonna give this one up
not in one eight nine one eight yeah
Vava voom the aqua queen indeed wah-wah
heinessen mmm
oh mama
wonderful indeed 9 1 8 Thank You aqua
Queen thank you they all hail Queen [ __ ]
what
alright 9 okay all right okay all right
all right all right
also I demand that everyone refer to me
as Big E from now on that is that is
just my forever nickname and forever
shall I reign me and my beautiful aqua
queen nine one eight I can't remember if
it was to the right first or left first
but there's only so many ways to get it
wrong okay I think nine one eight ah
don't tell Amy don't tell don't tell
Martha May who is who you shouldn't tell
why did a drug store owner have this
instead of cash in is say biggie like
biggie like Big E knows all right so I
need to go back to the safe room in the
donut shop real quick because I gotta
drop some stuff off in the whoo Zima
what's it what is that
portable generator that's probably
important when the main game comes out
I'll learn about that when the time
comes but for now I just need to drop
stuff off in here I've got red herbs
I don't need I was stupid about the
herbs I should know not to mix herbs
right away that that's like a basic
thing I'm pretty sure gunpowder I'll
hold on to that just because I'm sure
I'll get another one
but I do have plenty of ammo right now
so it doesn't really matter thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much thank you biggie appreciates
your love biggie precious biggie big
preesh
big he only knows big preesh and you
know who else knows big preesh cloak
brand.com you want to get some of the
new program nature there are some
legitimately cool stuff on the store
right now I love it is sold out but go
check it out if you want some cool new
stars cliff brand.com wait can I not but
no this is my genius moment I did my
plug and everything no no guys please
please God guys no guys please I swear I
did what ha ha right oh here we go
ok god I gotta gotta gotta get big all
right got it
hello boom oh well that doesn't really
help I mean I already kind of added
targeting because it cool but yeah ok
you know what I read I preached that I
big big priest across the board for the
big big red dot that's that's some good
stuff I thought that was a can of beans
turns out it was gunpowder first aid
spray love it love me for some first aid
spray all right can I get down there and
no I cannot so why did I come in here
what what was the point guys what was
the point
what was the point what was the point of
coming in here why is the spread did I
met was even the point
who's the point
all right all done there not too shabby
can't go in here alright guys that might
be lost
guys big a but biggie might not be big
brain right now biggie might be small
brain I hate to say it biggie looks like
looks like might be small brain biggie
why is this red here what is it
currently searching ok so there's
something else in the red area of which
there is something right in here right
where I am
there's something here why what could it
be I'm smart I'm big brain I big brain I
can figure this out is it this door is
it the door I'm big Brian I can I can
figure this out oh is it that door is
that all it is ok there's something else
down here too but I'm not on a percent
sure what there was there's nothing over
here
something over here maybe oh just
gunpowder that's it all right whatever I
guess that's something I've got too many
bullets um let me go drop off this
high-grade gunpowder guys I um
might be a little bit guys guys I I
really wish it weren't so I really wish
it weren't so turns out might be dumb
guys you know I hate ya you know I hate
you hate to see it but might be dumb
guys might be dumb there's a hose on the
ground somewhere I just got a telepathic
message I just got ESPN I just I felt it
in my bones there's a hose on the ground
somewhere here I knew it I I can feel it
I know what the game designers want of
me
biggie knows biggie knows about the hose
there's no guys there's no no huh
was it up here was up here here the hose
was it up here yes I know doom eternal
doom eternal is gonna start exactly
tomorrow don't you worry about doom
eternal I'll worry about do eternal
where's the hose I don't know where the
hose is gonna be I actually might be
dumb is the main problem and also very
hard to see through this helmet boy
biggie is letting you down guys
biggie let me down hard biggie really
not coming in clutch about this one is
just falling behind the big II don't
know what biggie doing
wants to succeed but big biggie don't
have time to
waste doing this this is why a live
stream is a mistake for someone as small
brain as me because I can't cut out the
moments in which I am dumb so big he
just has to kind of just put up with
Biggie's own small brains self so I'm
just gonna try to backtrack forever and
umbilicals I literally can't see I
literally can't see with that coming
around
that's a cool helmet okay alright biggie
coming through I'm gonna go through the
donut shop I'm gonna backtrack a little
bit on my check in the area that I was
before and hopefully something is gonna
pop out of me did I go back wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait oh my
god of course there was a whole nother
area that I hadn't gone through right
yeah yep okay that's good to know
okay what do we get over here oh [ __ ]
okay interesting fall down I'm waiting
for those guys to come around I'm gonna
shoot that barrel hey how you doing yeah
come on down yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah three two one that's a big old
barrel soup let me tell you about that
that is some quality soup okay you're
definitely down more gun ammo how much
more do you think I need I mean I put
whoa this was a mistake you should not
have given me this this was a mistake
good sir ooh well I I mean I guess I
don't really need it but whatever also
this didn't seem to wait
the grenade if I put the grenade by the
fire exceed Hrant she's gonna blow right
if I okay this is serious big brain time
if I blow up the fire hydrant I won't
need a hose you know this is I am you're
about to see the most 9,000 IQ play
you've ever seen in your life this is
how I separate the boys from the men and
it's all down to me
I just you know I just I just you know I
just feel like feel like a bit of a fool
I feel like a bit of a fool right now I
feel like I feel like I've I feel like
I've made a few mistakes in my life I
feel like feel like I've done wrong Lisa
Lisa
at least I still got my hair that was
really dumb
alright cool good so there must be
something else there must be some other
chain that I can cut in this far area
here because there's obviously nothing
here unless unless I go back track to
the beginning and then maybe there was
like a chain back there you know I said
about like hey the exploration in this
game is real cool I love that son of
stuff also I can get lost for it wait I
haven't been up here I haven't been here
at all
oh I'm Dom oh I'm so short goon whoa
shoot-down oh there's the HOS wait let
me see what's in here first huh huh
donuts
hey come on Jill have these people in
these apocalypse situations they're
gonna pass up a dozen donuts of
beautiful assorted flavors like that
you're just gonna look away nothing
nothing
mean nothing kite Bros railway manual
ensuring safe subway operations in the
event of a power outage the subway will
automatically see the operations once
power has been restored please use the
control panels to confirm the stations
in which the train will stop as well as
the track segments will be used if the
route entered is unsafe and error will
occur and operations will not resume
okay
so I need to find a way to get the power
back on that's probably due to the fire
that makes sense whoa hey no stay down
[ __ ] fire hose so kind of good got that
good good good good good I don't know
why I need a fire hose specifically I
could have just whoa oh you subway
employes memo violence getting worse and
worse these past few days got a shotgun
for when it hits a breaking point
locking it up in the gun rack that
should keep it safely from any would-be
looters while I go out and try to find
some more shells if things go south cut
the chain and Plus that and suck her out
I pray we all make it out alive
well good thing I got the very thing
that will bust open some chains right
here baby right here baby BAM oh I love
it okay this is pretty cool hey it only
takes up one spot sweet all right
items can be discarded that have served
their purpose okay this has no more
purpose discard it yes that's just I'm
just gonna move it
all right fire hose this fisted nope
let's put this to number three that
feels like a number three kind of weapon
then I can go get more other shotgun
shells I can make some shotgun shells -
and then bada bing bada boom and I'll
get out of here you still alive you are
aren't you
oh you are no he's not okay cool someone
trying to bust in oh really okay miss
okay miss okay hit all right good for
you
oh really
okay you know what I only have so many
of these but you know I feel like making
a example out of you
wasn't quite as brain as splode as I
would have hoped but hey it was good
enough all right cool so we got the fire
hose we should be able to go get uh I
mean maybe unless I need like some kind
of a wrench or something but we should
be able to go get what we need all right
the chaos of the outside is now finally
gone I'm gonna bring out this high-grade
gunpowder and I'm just gonna wanna price
shoot a shot in between now and then all
right let's do this
Oh
oh that oh that's not oh my god I was
not ready no I was not prepared for you
to be here what is this nonsense
Oh God do not okay okay okay
you know I don't like it I don't like it
not one bit
not one bit wow you suck all right I'm
gonna go around I'm gonna go around
around is good this is where the grenade
would come in handy
whoo you suck oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
okay he's down that's like the other guy
when he goes down he's down for a bit
okay all right I just gotta get through
the fire through the fire in the flames
I did not bring my god damn oh god he's
coming he's go no I got you I got you
Wow Wow I didn't touch that either I
don't have any medicine and I don't have
no medicine Oh God dodge Wow okay just
go go go go go I'm just gonna go I'm
just gonna go I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna go I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna go okay you fire hose use there we
go I have time for this I definitely
have time for this I definitely have all
the time in the world there pull calm
collected and run again
hi
ah 20 20 20 dolls 20 all right so that
is the end of the demo unfortunately
it's just demo but hey the full game is
coming out within a couple weeks thank
you all so much for watching tomorrow is
the start of doom eternal I am
unbelievably excited for that is going
to be so much fun if you want to check
out my playthrough your president evil 2
& 7 their link down the description
below you can check out the other
Resident Evil stuff all down there
there's tons of stuff going on thank you
everybody so much for watching and hey
today we launched another collection of
cloak and I wanted to let you guys know
that we are also taking a lot of
precautions to make sure that the
workers at the fulfillment center are
staying safe and healthy they're getting
gloves sterilization of the workspaces
more space in the workspace we want to
make sure that everyone is staying
healthy
remember coronavirus is very serious
make sure you're washing her hands stay
indoors playing games and just generally
being mindful of yourself and your
health so take it seriously take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
and thanks so much for watching this has
been big e with another big plays so
thanks again and if you want to check
out cloak brand it's linked in the
description cloak brand.com lots of cool
stuff there so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye bye
guys bye bye